CLUB.
THERE WAS ALSO ANOTHER CHINESE
NATIONAL ACCUSED OF TRESPASSING
AT MAR-A-LAGO LATER THAT YEAR.
TAKING CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE IS A CRIME.
IT MAY BE MANY CRIMES, AS
SPELLED OUT IN THE APPLICATION
FOR THE SEARCH WARRANT.
ACCORDING TO THAT DOCUMENT, THE
SPECIFIC CRIMES BEING
INVESTIGATED INCLUDE, QUOTE,
WILLFUL RETENTION OF NATIONAL
DEFENSE INFORMATION.
WE KNOW THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES
AND THE DOJ TRIED TO GET THOSE
CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS BACK FOR
MORE THAN A YEAR.
ACCORDING TO THREE OF TRUMP'S
ADVISERS, AS QUOTED IN THE "NEW
YORK TIMES," WHEN ASKED TO
RETURN THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS,
TRUMP SAID, QUOTE, THEY'RE MINE.
THE EX-PRESIDENT OFTEN CLAIMS
THAT THINGS THAT ACTUALLY BELONG
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE HIS.
>> I WANT MY GENERALS KICKING
ASS.
ALL I CAN DO IS ASK MY GENERALS.
I AUTHORIZED MY MILITARY.
MY PEOPLE ARE SO SMART.
MY JUSTICE DEPARTMENT -- I WANT
MY FARMERS.
I LOVE MY FARMERS.
LOOK AT MY AFRICAN AMERICAN OVER
HERE.
>> 18 TOP TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
OFFICIALS ARE PUSHING BACK ON
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S CLAIM
THAT HE HAD A STANDING ORDER TO
DECLASSIFY WHATEVER TOP SECRET
DOCUMENTS HE WANTED.
AMONG THEM, FORMER ACTING TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE CHIEF OF STAFF MICK
MULVANEY, WHO I SPOKE WITH A
SHORT TIME AGO.
>> THANKS SO MUCH FOR BEING
HERE, MICK.
>> ALISYN, THANKS FOR HAVING ME.
>> MICK, ARE YOU WORRIED ABOUT
THE 20-PLUS BOXES OF CLASSIFIED
MATERIAL THAT WAS SITTING IN
DONALD TRUMP'S BASEMENT AND WHO
MIGHT HAVE SEEN IT?
>> WORRIED?
NOT WORRIED.
I'M CURIOUS.
I SAW THE LIST THAT -- OF THINGS
THAT WERE REMOVED FROM
MAR-A-LAGO.
AND THE ONE THING THAT CAUGHT MY
ATTENTION, ALONG WITH I THINK
THE ATTENTION OF MOST PEOPLE,
WAS THAT ONE LIST THAT SAID
THERE WERE VARIOUS ITEMS MARKED
TS SCI.
THAT'S THE SERIOUS STUFF.
THAT'S TOP SECRET AND
COMPARTMENTALIZED INFORMATION.
THAT'S NOT SUPPOSED TO BE THERE.
THAT BEING SAID, IT'S REALLY
HARD TO SORT OF UNDERSTAND HOW
IT GETS THERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THESE THINGS ARE NOT SORT OF
ACCIDENTALLY MOVED ANYWHERE.
THESE DOCUMENTS ARE MARKED.
THEY ARE CLEARLY KNOWN TO FOLKS
TO BE TS SCI, AND THEY'RE
SUPPOSED TO BE, FOLKS, SORT OF
TRACKING WHERE THEY ARE.
SO, THE FACT THAT THAT DOCUMENT
OR IT COULD BE -- IT SAYS
VARIOUS DOCUMENTS -- WERE THERE
IS A QUESTION TO ME.
IT CONCERNS MEMENT I'M NOT SURE
IT JUSTIFIES A SEARCH WARRANT.
>> TELL ME ABOUT THAT.
I'M CURIOUS ABOUT THAT.
IF THEY'RE TOP SECRET, AS YOU
SAY, THE MOST SECRET
COMPARTMENTED INFO, WHY WOULDN'T
THAT WARRANT A SEARCH WARRANT?
>> A SEARCH IS IF IT'S AN
EMERGENCY.
IF EVIDENCE IS GOING TO BE
DESTROYED OR BE MOVED.
THERE'S AN URGENCY ABOVE A
SEARCH WARRANT THAT GOES ABOVE
JUST A SUBPOENA.
>> WHY DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT
TRUMP TOOK ALL THOSE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS HOME?
>> GOING OVER THIS IN MY HEAD,
AND DONALD TRUMP WOULD NOT HAVE
TAKEN IT IF HE DIDN'T PERCEIVE
IT TO BE IN HIS OWN INTEREST, OF
BENEFIT TO HIM.
IT'S EITHER THAT OR IT'S SHEER
SORT OF OVERSIGHT OR
INADVERTENCE.
THROW A BUNCH OF DOCUMENTS THE
IN A BOX BECAUSE YOU THINK
THEY'RE YOURS, AND THEY'RE GONE.
THIS IS TO BE A BIG PART OF ANY
SUBSEQUENT CRIMINAL CHARGE,
ALISYN, BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE TO SHOW WILLFUL INTENT THAT
THE PRESIDENT MEANT TO TAKE THE
DOCUMENTS, MEANT TO WITHHOLD THE
DOCUMENTS.
THEY'RE GOING TO HAVE TO SHOW HE
WAS WILLFUL OR ACTED
INTENTIONALLY.
>> THE APPLICATION FOR THE
SEARCH WARRANT GAVE US A LITTLE
BIT MORE INSIGHT.
IT DESCRIBED THE PROBABLE CAUSE
AS, QUOTE, WILLFUL RETENTION OF
NATIONAL DEFENSE INFORMATION.
AND THAT SOUNDS SERIOUS.
>> IT DOES.
AND IT SOUNDS LIKE THEY HAVE --
THEY HAVE TO HAVE EVIDENCE TO
THAT.
THEY CAN'T JUST SAY IT, RIGHT?
THEY HAVE TO PRESENT EVIDENCE TO
THE COURT TO SHOW PROBABLE
CAUSE.
IT'S NOT THE SAME LEVEL OF
EVIDENCE THAT YOU HAVE IN A
TRIAL.
AND CERTAINLY PROBABLE CAUSE IS
MUCH LOWER THAN BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT.
BUT YOU CAN'T JUST SORT OF WILLY
NILLY SAY, OH, WE'VE GOT A HUNCH
THERE'S DOCUMENTS.
THEY HAVE TO HAVE SOMETHING.
AND THE FACT THEY CAN FILL OUT
THAT AFFIDAVIT TELLS ME THEY
THINK THEY HAVE SOMETHING.
>> HOW MUCH RESPONSIBILITY DO
YOU THINK FALLS ON THE PEOPLE
AROUND DONALD TRUMP WHOM HE
TASKED REPORTEDLY WITH DEALING
WITH THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES,
PEOPLE LIKE MARK MEADOWS BACK IN
JANUARY.
AND THEN IN JUNE, JOHN SOLOMON
AND KASH PATEL?
>> ULTIMATELY, THE PRESIDENT IS
RESPONSIBLE.
HE JUST IS.
THAT'S HIM.
THAT'S BIDEN.
THAT'S OBAMA.
THAT'S BUSH.
THE BUCK STOPS AT THE OVAL
OFFICE.
IT ABSOLUTELY DOES.
THAT BEING SAID, AS A FORMER
CHIEF OF STAFF, I THOUGHT IT WAS
MY JOB AND MY DUTY TO MAKE SURE
THAT I WAS MAKING THE PRESIDENT
AS SUCCESSFUL AS POSSIBLE.
AND THAT INCLUDES FOLLOWING THE
LAW.
AND IF WE WERE THERE, IF MY TEAM
HAD BEEN THERE, WE WOULD HAVE
BEEN PAYING VERY CLOSE ATTENTION
TO THE PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS ACT,
TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE
NATIONAL ARCHIVES.
MY GUT, ALISYN, IS THAT THINGS
WERE SO HECTIC AND SO CHAOTIC,
ESPECIALLY AFTER JANUARY 6th, NO
ONE WAS WATCHING THE SHOP.
PEOPLE HAD LEFT OR TRYING TO
LEAVE AND LOOKING FOR THE NEXT
JOB AND SORT OF, LET'S GET OUT
OF TOWN.
IT GOES BACK TO THE WILLFUL
INTENT VERSUS INADVERTENCE.
YOU'RE CORRECT IN SAYING THE FBI
THINKS THEY HAVE SOME EVIDENCE
OF INTENTION.
IT WOULDN'T SURPRISE ME IF THE
PLACE IN THE FINAL DAYS OF THAT
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION WERE
ABSOLUTELY CHAOS IN THE
BUILDING.
>> BUT IF IT WERE OPERATING
NORMALLY, THE CHIEF OF STAFF,
MARK MEADOWS, WOULD HAVE BEEN IN
CHARGE OF THAT.
>> YEAH.
I THINK HE COULD PROBABLY MAKE
THE CASE THAT THE OVAL OFFICE
WASN'T OPERATING ANYWHERE NEAR
WHATEVER NORMAL IS LONG BEFORE
JANUARY 20th AND LONG BEFORE
JANUARY 6th.
YOU DON'T GET JANUARY 6th WITH A
PROPERLY FUNCTIONING WEST WING.
YOU DON'T GET INADVERTENT
COLLECTION OF DOCUMENTS WITH A
PROPERLY FUNCTIONING WEST WING.
YOU DON'T GET SOMEBODY GOING ON
TV AND SAYING, OH, THE PRESIDENT
CAN WAVE A MAGIC WAND AND
DECLASSIFY EVERYTHING HE WANTS
TO IN A PROPERLY FUNCTIONING
WEST WING.
AND THAT'S WHAT WE'RE SEEING OUT
OF THE LAST DAYS OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
>> AND BY THE WAY, THAT WAVING
THE MAGIC WAND, YOU'VE BASICALLY
CALLED NONSENSE.
>> I KNOW WHAT I KNOW.
WE DIDN'T HAVE IT WHEN I WAS
THERE.
I WAS NOT AWARE OF IT WHEN I WAS
IT WOULD SURPRISE ME IF THEY DID
IT LATER.
I KNOW WE DECLASSIFIED SOME
DOCUMENTS WHEN I WAS THERE.
I THINK WE WENT THROUGH THE
PROCESS OF DECLASSIFYING THE
TRANSCRIPT OF THE PHONE CALL
WITH PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY OF
UKRAINE THAT LED TO THE FIRST
IMPEACHMENT.
IF THERE WERE A BLANKET SORT OF
DECLASSIFICATION ORDER IN PLACE,
WHY WOULD ANY OF US HAVE WORRIED
ABOUT DECLASSIFYING THE
TRANSCRIPT WITH UKRAINE?
>> WHEN YOU SAY THERE WAS A
PROCESS FOR DECLASSIFYING IT
WITH ZELENSKYY, HOW COMPLICATED
WAS THAT PROCESS?
>> YOU KNOW, IT WASN'T
COMPLICATED.
IT WAS JUST REAL.
IT WAS FORMAL.
THERE WERE THINGS TO DO.
THERE WAS A PAPER TRAIL TO LAY
OUT.
AND THERE WAS -- JUST LIKE
EVERYTHING THAT HAPPENS IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, NOTHING SORT OF
JUST HAPPENS BY MAGIC.
THERE ARE RULES THAT GOVERN HOW
WE HANDLE DOCUMENTS.
WE ALL KNEW THESE RULES.
THE STAFF SECRETARY IS A
POSITION IN THE WHITE HOUSE THAT
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THINGS LIKE
PRESERVATION OF RECORDS AND
WOULD BE HEAVILY INVOLVED IN
DECLASSIFYING ANY RECORDS AS
WOULD THE WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL'S
OFFICE.
I WOULD BE CURIOUS TO KNOW IF
PAT CIPOLLONE, IF I ASKED HIM
ABOUT THE CLASSIFICATION
DOCUMENTS.
IT WOULD BE UNHEARD OF I THINK
TO GO THROUGH A DECLASSIFICATION
PROCESS AND NOT INVOLVE THE
WHITE HOUSE COUNSEL'S OFFICE.
THINGS IN THE WHITE HOUSE ARE
SUPPOSED TO WORK IN A PROPER
WAY, AND IT SOUNDS LIKE, AGAIN,
THEY DIDN'T IN THE LATE DAYS OF
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
>> IN YOUR EXPERIENCE, HOW
CAREFUL WAS DONALD TRUMP WITH
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL?
>> HE WAS PRETTY GOOD.
I DON'T WANT TO GO TO SPECIFICS
ON CLASSIFIED.
TRUMP WAS AN INFORMAL GUY.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT.
BUT HE KNEW THE SEVERITY OF
THESE DOCUMENTS.
AND IMPORTANTLY, THERE WAS A
SYSTEM IN PLACE TO MAKE SURE
THAT REGARDLESS OF HOW THE
PRESIDENT WANTED TO ACT OR
BEHAVE, THERE WAS A SYSTEM TO
PROTECT THINGS.
I'VE SAID BEFORE, YES, I SAW THE
PRESIDENT RIP DOCUMENTS IN HALF.
NOT CONFIDENTIAL DOCUMENTS BUT
JUST DRAFT DOCUMENTS.
NOT SUPPOSED TO DO THAT, BUT
THERE'S A WAY TO FIX IT, WHICH
IS YOU FIND THE PIECES AND TAPE
THEM TOGETHER.
I USED TO RIP UP DOCUMENTS IN
THE PRIVATE SECTOR ALL THE TIME.
IT'S NOT AN INDICATION OF ANY
ILL-INTENT.
>> YES -- BUT I MEAN -- SORRY TO
INTERRUPT.
BUT I'M TALKING ABOUT THE STUFF
THAT WE ALL KNEW.
THERE WERE MOMENTS PUBLICLY,
LIKE WHEN HE SHARED THE -- IN
2017, HE SHARED THE CLASSIFIED
ISRAELI INFORMATION WITH THE
RUSSIANS.
AND THE ISRAELIS WERE APOPLECTIC
ABOUT THAT.
HOW IS THAT NOT SLOPPY AND
DANGEROUS?
>> AGAIN, I WASN'T IN THE WHITE
HOUSE AT THAT TIME.
MY EXPERIENCE WITH THAT IS JUST
WHAT I SAW FROM THE MEDIA.
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO HANDLE IT.
THE STAFF IS SUPPOSED TO GET
INVOLVED.
IF THE PRESIDENT HAS
CONFIDENTIAL MATERIALS ON HIS
DESK AT THE END OF ONE MEETING,
WHICH IS POSSIBLE -- AND LIKELY.
IT HAPPENS, RIGHT?
THE STAFF COMES IN TO MAKE SURE
THAT ALL OF THAT STUFF IS GONE
AND PUT IN THE PROPER PLACE
BEFORE THE NEXT MEETING TAKES
PLACE.
YOU CAN'T CONTROL THE PRESIDENT.
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO DO
WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO
DO.
BUT THERE ARE MECHANISMS INSIDE
EVERY PROPERLY FUNCTIONING WEST
WING TO MAKE SURE THE LAW IS
FOLLOWED, DOCUMENTS ARE
PRESERVED, AND THE CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION IS TREATED AS
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION.
>> WHILE I HAVE YOU, I WANT TO
ASK YOU ABOUT THIS BECAUSE
FORMER VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE
HAS SAID PUBLICLY THAT HE MIGHT
BE WILLING TO CONSIDER SPEAKING
TO THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
SHOULD HE DO THAT?
>> YEAH, I DON'T SEE THE HARM IN
IT.
I THINK MIKE KNOWS THAT -- THE
VICE PRESIDENT -- I'M SORRY.
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE KNOWS IT TO
BE WHAT I BELIEVE IT TO BE,
WHICH IS A POLITICAL THING.
IT IS A COMMITTEE OF POLITICIANS
WHO DON'T LIKE DONALD TRUMP
TRYING TO MAKE DONALD TRUMP LOOK
BAD.
THAT'S FINE.
THAT'S POLITICS IN WASHINGTON,
D.C.
BUT THEY REALLY COLLECTED GOOD
INFORMATION.
WHEN YOU GET THE REPUBLICAN
ATTORNEY GENERAL UNDER OATH
GIVING TESTIMONY, I TESTIFIED TO
THE COMMITTEE.
I CAN ASSURE YOU I THINK I GAVE
THEM GOOD AND TRUE AND ACCURATE
INFORMATION.
WE SHOULD NEVER BE AFRAID OF
GOOD AND TRUE AND ACCURATE
INFORMATION.
AND I KNOW THAT MIKE PENCE IS
NOT.
SO, I WOULD HAVE NO DIFFICULTY
WITH HIM TESTIFYING.
I THINK IF HE HAS INFORMATION
THAT HE THINK WOULD SHED LIGHT
ON JANUARY 6th SO THAT WE CAN
TAKE STEPS TO MAKE SURE IT
DOESN'T HAPPEN AGAIN, I THINK
THAT WOULD BE A VALUABLE THING
FOR HIM TO DO.
>> AND HOW COULD HE NOT HAVE
RELEVANT INFORMATION ON JANUARY
6th, GIVEN WHAT WE SAW HIM
ENDURE?
>> I THINK THAT'S FAIR.
HE HAD PRIVATE CONVERSATIONS